Albert Watkins represented Jacob
chansley at his trial he had not seen
that video evidence until we broadcast
it on Monday and we're happy to have him
join us now Mr Watkins thank you for
coming on if you could just vote restate
clearly just to make sure that you know
I don't want to put words in your mouth
had you seen that clearly exculpatory
tape of your client at trial
no
we went through extraordinary efforts on
behalf of our client to put him in a
position of knowledge that's my duty as
an agent of the court to make sure that
he knew everything that the government
had good and bad
to put him in that position to make a
learned informed voluntary decision
about whether to go to trial or take a
plea and remember this is a man who had
tremendous intelligence very gentle very
very articulate
who was diagnosed 15 years earlier by
the by the government with a mental
health issue
and the government knew that the
government knew through three hearings
when we begged and pleaded to get this
man out of solitary confinement
literally falling into an abyss mentally
and through each of those three hearings
that government assistant U.S attorney
knew the most important aspect of that
hearing was that Jake was not violent
the government knew
they knew that Jake had walked around
with all of these police officers they
had that video footage I didn't get it
it wasn't disclosed to me it wasn't
provided to me I would question it I
filed the requisite pleading for it and
whether I did or not they had a duty an
absolute Duty with zero discretion to
provide it to me so that I could share
it with my client I know very simple
question this is it's shocking that this
could happen and happen with the
knowledge of Liz Cheney and Adam
kinziger and Chuck Schumer and all the
ghouls around the story how can this man
still be in prison tonight he's still in
jail tonight right now
well it's a tragedy I mean what's
happened is truly a dagger in the heart
of our American justice system we can't
we can't allow it and but for you
disclosing it and whether this isn't
about you this isn't about January 6th
this is about our this is about our
justice system being so compromised the
very integrity and core of that which we
wore as a badge of honor for the
entirety of our nation's history has
been rendered a vile disgusting Mess by
a department of justice that was running
a month and they didn't share the video
of my client the footage of my client
with nine officers surrounding him
peacefully wondering about trying to
help him trying to get him access to the
the Senate chamber they didn't because
it didn't fit their narrative
and but for you disclosing it
I don't know where we'd be yeah why it
is why they're attacking you makes no
sense at all because by doing that
they're shrouding in secrecy or trying
to their own assault on democracy
yeah I mean it's dogs barking to me I'm
speaking for myself I don't care at all
but I I feel for this man who I've never
met sitting in jail tonight I mean it's
it's really it is a tremendous
intelligent peaceful man
Albert Watkins his former attorney thank
you so much for that I appreciate it my
pleasure hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else